robert de niro is in a duel of lawsuits
with his former assistant who accuses
him of sexual and verbal harassment
chase Robinson filed her 12 million
dollar lawsuit yesterday the two-time
Oscar winner sued Robinson back in
August for six million dollars after she
stopped working for his production
company or a national correspondent
Jericka Duncan is here with more on this
story
Jericka there are big allegations on
both sides what are they saying yes
there are good morning DeNiro is
accusing her of misappropriating money
she claims the 76 year old made sexually
charged comments and often spoke to her
in a demeaning way while she's backing
up some of those allegations with a
voicemail that appears to have come from
DeNiro people don't respect him they
fear Him award-winning actor Robert De
Niro best known for his violent and
abrasive roles in movies is facing
accusations of verbal harassment and
discrimination from a former female
employee who worked for the star for
more than a decade
chase Robinson De Niro's former
assistant and vice-president of
production and finance at his company
canal productions filed a 12 million
dollar lawsuit against the star in it
she claims De Niro would unleash drunked
high raids against her in which he
denigrated berated bullied and hurled
expletives the lawsuit includes a vulgar
voicemail De Niro allegedly made to
Robinson in 2012 calling her a spoiled
brat
DeNiro who has two major films about to
be released Joker and the Irishman filed
a 6 million dollar lawsuit against
Robinson nearly seven weeks ago claiming
she misappropriated hundreds of
thousands of dollars and loafed during
working hours binge watching astounding
hours of TV shows on Netflix his lawsuit
conveys the message don't cross me
Robinson's Attorney Alexandra Harwin
says De Niro's lawsuit is an act of
intimidation
she did attempt to quit multiple times
and mr. DeNiro responded by promising
things would get better and threatening
her if she left Robinson abruptly
resigned from canal productions in April
her lawyer says DeNiro only filed a
lawsuit when he heard that she
considered filing one De Niro's attorney
tells CBS News Robinson's allegations
are beyond absurd these are very messy
he said she says about why she held that
that a phone call for 12 that was done
the 2000-2012
seven years for seven years I think
that's interesting it's messy